SECRETARY DeVOS, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US, DELIGHTED TO HAVE
YOU HERE.
>> Secretary DeVos: THANKS SO
MUCH.
>> Governor Huckabee: IT’S NOT
JUST K-12 EDUCATION THAT DEMANDS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION’S
ATTENTION, HIGHER EDUCATION HAS
BECOME A BASTION OF SPEECH
CODES, CONSERVATIVE
INTIMIDATION, AND MUCH WORSE.
TAKE THE UNIVERSITY OF SO MAIN,
PLEASE, TAKE THEM.
THEY ARE NOW ASKING COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO SIGN A BLACK LIVES
MATTER STATEMENT AND ANTIRACISM
PLEDGE.
WHAT’S WORSE, THE SCHOOL ALSO
PUBLISHED THE NAMES OF PEOPLE
WHO SIGNED IT, WHICH IN THIS
POLITICAL CLIMATE MEANS THAT
THOSE WHO DON’T SIGN IT WILL
ALMOST CERTAINLY FACE
RETALIATION AND MAYBE EVEN HAVE
MOMS SHOWING UP AT THEIR HOME.
JOINING ME NOW, JOHN EASTMAN,
CLAREMONT INSTITUTE SENIOR
FELLOW AND CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR.
THIS IS A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY.
PEOPLE PAY TAXES AND THAT IS
WHAT FUNDS THIS PLACE, AND THEY
ARE BASICALLY THREATENING THE
STAFF INTO SIGNING A POLITICAL
DOCUMENT.
IS THAT EVEN LEGAL?
>> IT’S NOT LEGAL, IT’S NOT
CONSTITUTIONAL, AND IT’S BEEN
THAT WAY FOR DECADES AND
DECADES.
THE SUPREME COURT A LONG TIME
AGO IN A CASE DEALING WITH
JEHOVAH’S WITNESSES, SAYING THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE, IT’S A
VERY FAMOUS LINE IN
SUPREME COURT JURISPRUDENCE, "IF
THERE IS ANY FIXED STAR IN OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL -- IT’S CANNOT
DESCRIBE WHAT CAN BE ORTHODOX IN
POLITICS, RELIGION, OR FORCE
CITIZENS," THIS IS A
STANDARD OF FIRST AMENDMENT LAW,
YOU CAN’T COMPEL PEOPLE TO TAKE
PARTICULAR POSITION.
WHEN YOU UNIVERSITY OR MORE
BROADLY.
>> Governor Huckabee: SO JOHN,
SOMEBODY DOESN’T SIGN LESS, DO
THEY SUE THE UNIVERSITY, AND HOW
LONG DOES THAT TAKE TO WRAP
THROUGH THE COURTS?
>> WELL, THAT’S GOING TO TAKE A
LONG TIME, BUT I WOULD BE
CONCERNED IF THEY ARE FIRED, IF
THEIR TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT ARE
AFFECTED THEREBY, AND A LOOK, WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
PROPAGANDA NATURE OF THIS.
THE SAME THING HAPPENED SOME
YEARS AGO WITH THE SAFE SPACE
MOVEMENT, WHERE FACULTY THAT
WERE FULLY SUPPORTER OF THE
HOMOSEXUAL RIGHTS AGENDA WOULD
PUT SAFE SPACE STICKERS ON THEIR
IMPLICATION, OF COURSE, WAS
IF YOU DIDN’T GO ALONG WITH THAT
AGENDA AND PUT THAT STICKER UP,
YOU ARE AN UNSAFE SPACE.
THE SAME THING IS BEING SOUGHT
HERE, IF YOU DON’T SIGN THIS
ANTIRACIST PLEDGE -- WHICH IS
ITSELF RACIST, YOU KNOW, THE
AUTHOR OF THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
THING HAS ADMITTED HE WANTS TO
REVERSE RACISM.
IF YOU DON’T SIGN IT, BY
DEFINITION, YOU ARE THE OPPOSITE
OF ANTIRACIST, WHICH MUST BE
RACIST.
WHAT’S PURE PROPAGANDA, IT HAS
NO PLACE IN AN INSTITUTE OF
GOVERNMENTAL INSTITUTION, A
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY.
AT SOME POINT, WE HAVE TO QUIT
CALLING THEM HIGHER EDUCATION,
THAT IS BECOMING A CONTRADICTION
IN TERMS.
>> Governor Huckabee: THE
PRESIDENT APPOINTS JUDGES, AND
REGARDLESS OF WHO THE PRESIDENT
IS.
DO YOU THINK AMERICANS ARE
FINALLY BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND JUST
HOW CRITICAL IT IS THAT WE HAVE
A PRESIDENT THAT APPOINTS JUDGES
WHO ACTUALLY HAVE READ AND
BELIEVES IN THE CONSTITUTION?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT’S RIGHT,
AND WE SHOULD BE REALLY CLEAR
HERE.
PEOPLE ARE NOT CHEERING BECAUSE
THIS PRESIDENT APPOINTED
CONSERVATIVES OR LIBERALS TO
ADVANCE AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
CONSERVATIVE AGENDA.
INSTEAD OF AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
LIBERAL AGENDA.
WHAT THEIR CHEERING IS THAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS APPOINTED PEOPLE
WHO ARE FAITHFUL TO THE LANGUAGE
OF THE CONSTITUTION, AS
ORIGINALLY UNDERSTOOD, AND KNOW
THE LIMITS OF THEIR AUTHORITY